Over the past several years, climate change has moved from an abstract idea to a reality in many of our lives, a reality that has a lot of us increasingly worried. An APA survey in February 2020 found that two-thirds of American adults said that they felt at least a little eco-anxiety, which is defined as worry or concern about climate change and its effects. And nearly half of those under age 34 said that stress about climate change affects their daily lives. Since then, hurricanes in the South, wildfires in the West, and an unprecedented ice storm in Texas have kept climate change in our thoughts this year even as COVID-19 has dominated the headlines.
在过去几年里，气候变化已经从一个抽象的概念变成了我们许多人生活中的现实，这种现实让我们许多人越来越担忧。美国心理学协会（APA）在2020年2月进行的一项调查发现，三分之二的美国成年人表示他们至少感到一点生态焦虑，生态焦虑被定义为对气候变化及其影响的忧虑或担心。在34岁以下的人群中，近一半的人表示气候变化的压力影响了他们的日常生活。自那以后，南方的飓风、西部的野火以及德克萨斯州前所未有的冰暴，使气候变化今年一直留在我们的脑海中，尽管新冠疫情（COVID-19）一直占据着头条新闻。
So what are the mental health effects of climate change? Who is most at risk of suffering eco-anxiety? What is ecological grief? And what can we do to cope and build resilience in ourselves when prospects for the future of the planet seems so bleak? to speaking of psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills.
那么气候变化对心理健康有什么影响？谁最容易受到生态焦虑的折磨？什么是生态悲伤？当这个星球未来的前景显得如此黯淡时，我们能做些什么来应对并在内心建立韧性？欢迎收听“心理学话你知”（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，主要探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。
We have two guests today. First is Dr. Thomas Doherty, a clinical and environmental psychologist in Portland, Oregon, who studies nature-based therapies, that is, the restorative effects of outdoor experience and the mental health impacts of climate change. His 2011 paper, the psychological impacts of global climate change, has been cited by other researchers more than 500 times. He's a fellow of APA, a contributor to the Association's 2017 report Mental Health and Our Changing Climate, and a founding editor of the journal Ecosycology. Also with us is Dr. Ashley Consolo, founding dean of the School of Arctic
我们今天请到了两位嘉宾。首先是托马斯·多尔蒂（Thomas Doherty）博士，他是俄勒冈州波特兰市的一名临床和环境心理学家，主要研究基于自然的疗法，也就是户外经历的恢复性效果以及气候变化对心理健康的影响。他2011年的论文《全球气候变化的心理影响》已被其他研究人员引用了500多次。他是美国心理学协会的资深会员（fellow），也是该协会2017年报告《心理健康与我们不断变化的气候》的撰稿人之一，同时也是《生态心理学》（Ecosycology）杂志的创始编辑。与我们一同出席的还有阿什利·孔索洛（Ashley Consolo）博士，她是加拿大纽芬兰纪念大学拉布拉多研究所北极与副北极研究学院的创始院长。
and Subarctic Studies at the Labrador Institute of Memorial University in Newfoundland, Canada. Dr. Consolo is a public health researcher who has spent more than a decade studying how climate climate change and environmental losses are affecting the mental health of the indigenous Inuit community in Canada, as well as developing programs to help the community deal with those losses. With other researchers, she coined the term ecological grief to describe the grief people feel at environmental loss, including loss caused by climate change. Thank you both for joining us today. Welcome. Thank you, Kim.
孔索洛博士是一位公共卫生研究人员，她花了十多年时间研究气候变化和环境损失如何影响加拿大本土因纽特（Inuit）社区的心理健康，并开发项目帮助该社区应对这些损失。她与其他研究人员一起创造了“生态悲伤”（ecological grief）一词，用来描述人们在面对环境损失（包括气候变化造成的损失）时感到的悲痛。非常感谢二位今天能来做客。欢迎。谢谢金。
It's great to be here, Kim. So Dr. Doherty, let's start with you. Those numbers I cited in the introduction from APA survey last year were very high. More than two-thirds of Americans said that they feel some eco-anxiety. And a number I didn't mention is that more than half of respondents said they felt that climate change was the biggest issue facing society today. As a clinician and practicing psychologist, does this ring true for you? Is this something that you're seeing in your practice?
很高兴来到这里，金。那么，多尔蒂博士，我们先从您开始谈起。我在引言中提到APA去年调查中的那些数字非常高。超过三分之二的美国人表示他们感受到了某种生态焦虑。还有一个我没有提到的数字，即超过一半的受访者表示，他们认为气候变化是当今社会面临的最大问题。作为一名临床医生和执业心理学家，这听起来符合实际吗？这是你在执业中看到的情况吗？
Yes, it does, Kim. It does ring true. I mean, those numbers are kind of sobering, but I'm, I'm really, really not surprised. I've known of Ashley's work and we've been in contact for many years. Maybe it may be as much as a decade. And, you know, things were different when we first started corresponding in terms of the distance of climate change and the abstract nature of it. But that really has changed. We knew that was going to change. That was what the predictions of scientists, you know, atmospheric scientists were. But it has changed. So people do have direct experience of
是的，金，确实如此。这听起来确实符合实际。我的意思是，这些数字有点让人清醒，但我其实一点也不感到意外。我一直知道阿什利的著作，我们已经联系很多年了。也许有十年之久了。而且，你知道的，当我们刚开始通信时，情况有所不同，当时气候变化还很遥远，性质也很抽象。但这种情况确实发生了变化。我们知道它会发生变化。这就是科学家的预测，你知道的，大气科学家的预测。但它确实变了。所以人们对气候变化有了直接的体验。
climate change. And I do think when we're when we're talking about issues like eco-anxiety or Rico Grief, we were talking about at least two things. One is more of a sociological, cultural, wide reckoning with this issue, climate change, much like we reckoned with, say, the nuclear war in the 1950s and 60s, and it was a big cultural debate, and it was a very troubling politicized issue. And same with climate change. People have, it is normal to be anxious about climate change. And then also, as a clinician, I start to think about people's functioning, and then we get into the realm of disorders and anxiety disorders, depression disorders, and there's a spectrum from, you know, healthy adjustments to stressors to adjustment disorders and then diagnosable issues. So I think,
而且我确实认为，当我们谈论像生态焦虑或生态悲伤这样的话题时，我们至少在讨论两件事。一是关于这个议题（气候变化）的社会、文化层面的广泛清算，很像我们在20世纪50年代和60年代清算核战争时那样，它曾是一场巨大的文化辩论，是一个非常令人不安的政治化议题。气候变化也是如此。人们感到焦虑是正常的。其次，作为一名临床医生，我开始思考人们的功能表现，然后我们就会进入失调和焦虑障碍、抑郁障碍的领域，这里存在一个谱系，你知道的，从对压力的健康适应到适应障碍，再到可诊断的问题。所以我认为，
you know, when we get into this topic, it's helpful to, it's helpful to make sure that we're, we realize there's a number of ways to think about eco-anxiety. Dr. Consul, you're not a practitioner, but are you experiencing the same kinds of reactions from the people you work with? Yeah, certainly. I mean, I think in the research that I'm doing and with people who are on the ground and particularly people living in northern Canada who are at the front lines of a rapidly changing climate, this is something that people are experiencing directly. It's something they've been living with and adapting to for decades. It's something that has been a mental health stressor, both directly creating new stressors, but also magnifying other underlying mental health conditions or mental health challenges. And it's something that you're really seeing like research is focusing on it more and more. I'm getting contacted more and more by interested grad students, which is really exciting. You know, people see the importance of this
你知道的，当我们深入探讨这个话题时，确保我们意识到有多种方式来思考生态焦虑，这会很有帮助。孔索洛博士，你不是执业心理学家，但你是否也从你共事的人身上经历了同类反应？是的，当然。我的意思是，我认为在我正在进行的研究中，以及与实地的人们，特别是生活在经历快速变化气候最前沿的加拿大北部的人们一起工作时，这是人们正在直接经历的事情。这是他们几十年来一直在生活和适应的事情。它一直是心理健康的一个压力源，既直接产生了新的压力源，又放大了其他潜在的心理健康状况或心理健康挑战。而且你可以真正看到，研究越来越关注这一点。
and want to go into this field now, which you know, as Thomas mentioned, when we first started corresponding 10 years ago, it wasn't, it was a new area, it was something new people were considering. And now we're seeing it as an emergence of a very important pressing field that more and more research is going into,
越来越多的感兴趣的研究生联系我，这真的让人很兴奋。你知道的，人们看到了这一领域的重要性，现在想进入这个领域，你知道的，正如托马斯所提到的，当我们10年前刚开始通信时，它还不是，这是一个新领域，是人们正在考虑的新事物。而现在我们看到它正在成为一个非常重要、迫切的领域，越来越多的研究投入其中，
more and more research funding, and more and more interests. And I think also in the kind of public conversation and dialogue and debate, we're seeing a lot of discussion in the media and a lot of focus around eco-anxiety, eco-grief, how people are experiencing this and choosing to narrate their own sort of self-reported experiences.
越来越多的研究经费，以及越来越多的兴趣。而且我认为，在公众的讨论、对话和辩论中，我们也看到媒体上有大量的讨论，以及围绕生态焦虑、生态悲伤的极大关注，人们是如何经历这些的，并选择叙述他们自己那种自我报告的经历。
So, you know, as Thomas said, those numbers from the APA survey are sobering, but not surprising. And I think it's great that we're starting to get a broader understanding of the prevalence in the distribution of how many people are actually being affected to various degrees by climate change and on their mental health.
所以，你知道的，正如托马斯所说，APA调查的那些数字虽然清醒，但并不令人意外。我认为很好的一点是，我们开始对气候变化对人们心理健康的实际影响程度（从不同程度来看）的普遍性和分布有了更广泛的了解。
In a 2017 report, APA and the climate nonprofit group, Eco America, actually came up with the term eco-anxiety and defined it as chronic fear of environmental doom. And while the term has caught on, it's not a clinical diagnosis. But how do psychologists think about defining and recognizing and ultimately treating eco-anxiety? It's a real thing, right? Yeah, as I said, I've been, again,
在2017的一份报告中，APA和气候非营利组织“生态美国”（Eco America）实际上提出了“生态焦虑”（eco-anxiety）这个词，并将其定义为对环境厄运的慢性恐惧。虽然这个词已经流行开来，但它并不是一个临床诊断。但是心理学家是如何思考定义、识别并最终治疗生态焦虑的呢？这是一件真实存在的事，对吧？是的，正如我所说，我一直是，
Psychology is a broad field. I have colleagues and Ashley and other folks that we know. We're studying this on a cultural level. You know, what people's people's basic identity, their values, their sense of themselves. You know, I use the term environmental identity a lot, and that's an important construct here. People have a sense of their identity in relation to nature and the natural world, much like their cultural identity or their gender identity or their ethnic identity. People are being, you know, their consciousness is being raised about their environmental identity with, issues like climate change. Obviously, you know, First Nations people in the in the Arctic and
心理学是一个广阔的领域。我有同事和阿什利以及我们认识的其他朋友。我们正在从文化层面上研究这个问题。你知道的，人们的基本认同、他们的价值观、他们的自我意识。你知道的，我经常使用“环境认同”（environmental identity）这个词，这是这里的一个重要概念。人们对自然和自然世界有着一种认同感，就像他们的文化认同、性别认同或族裔认同一样。人们的意识正在被唤醒，通过诸如气候变化之类的问题来认识他们的环境认同。很明显，你知道的，北极的第一民族（First Nations）和
indigenous people have a very well-developed sense of environmental identity based on their culture and their values and their spirituality. But people in the in the in the sort of regular world also have various kinds of environmental identities. And so when we it's a healthy way to start talking about this concept to this topic of environmental environmental anxiety. We get anxious or we have grief because we have things that we value are threatened. You know, either personally or things that we value our threat or we witness this. And then it causes us to have these emotions. Dr. Consolo in your work, you do talk a lot about ecological grief. How does that relate to eco-anxiety? And where do the two terms overlap and how are they different? I think they overlap in a great way. You know,
原住民根据他们的文化、价值观和灵性，对环境认同有着非常成熟的意识。但在所谓常规世界中的人们也拥有各种各样的环境认同。因此，当我们开始用一种健康的方式来谈论环境焦虑这一概念和话题时。我们感到焦虑或悲伤，是因为我们所珍视的事物受到了威胁。你知道的，无论是个人层面的，还是我们珍视的事物受到威胁，或者是我们目睹了这一切。然后它导致我们产生这些情绪。孔索洛博士，在你的工作中，你确实经常谈到生态悲伤。这与生态焦虑有什么关系？这两个术语在哪里重叠，它们又有什么不同？我认为它们在很大程度上是重叠的。你知道的，
The anxiety that people feel, as Thomas just said, is related to the things that they're worried about losing. So whether it's their environmental identity or their cultural or their social identity or things that are important to them in their lives or in the case of very acute things like wildfires or flooding where it's actual destruction and loss, there's anxiety related to that and related to future thinking around knowing what's to come. And then there's also the associated grief. And for a lot of people, at least what I'm seeing in my own research and what people are identifying and say, you know, media reports or we're seeing documentaries and other forms of expression, anxiety and grief are starting to go hand in hand. So people are feeling anxious of other changes and then they're grieving both the current changes that they might be experiencing or the future loss that might be coming. So there's this current temporal experience of both anxiety and grief and then there's also this future fear. And a lot of people talk about mourning what's to come.
正如托马斯刚刚所说，人们感受到的焦虑与他们担心失去的事物有关。因此，无论是他们的环境认同、文化或社会认同，还是他们生活中对他们重要的事情，或者在面对非常剧烈的事情（如野火或洪水，那是实际的破坏和损失）时，都会产生与之相关的焦虑，以及围绕对未来的思考（知道即将发生什么）的焦虑。此外，还有与之相关的悲伤。对于许多人来说，至少从我自己的研究中以及人们在媒体报道中（或者我们看到的纪录片和其他表达形式中）所识别的内容来看，焦虑和悲伤开始齐头并进了。所以人们对其他的变化感到焦虑，然后他们为可能正在经历的当前变化或即将到来的未来损失感到悲伤。因此，这里存在着一种焦虑和悲伤的当下时间体验，同时也存在着这种对未来的恐惧。许多人谈论哀悼即将到来的事情。
And I think this is a really fascinating piece that we need to grapple with when we're thinking about what type of stressors people are experiencing daily, because sometimes the biggest stresses are coming from future and anticipating future. So for me, the grief is the peace that's lost and the pain that's experienced when we know what's lost, because we only grieve what we love.
我认为这是一个非常迷人的部分，当我们在思考人们每天都在经历什么类型的压力源时，我们必须与之搏斗，因为有时最大的压力来自于未来和对未来的预期。对我来说，悲伤是失去的东西以及当我们知道失去了什么时所经历的痛苦，因为我们只会为我们所爱的事物感到悲伤。
And when we lose something that we love, there's that act of mourning and grief. And the anxiety is a part of that because you can have anxiety before the grief during and after. So they're very interlinked and there's certainly something that people often articulate together. And I found in my own research, you know, people will talk about anxiety and then start to talk about how that anxiety points to future grief that they're afraid of. So they're kind of linking even if they haven't hit the grief stage yet. Can I suggest that there might be other terms out there that maybe haven't been coined yet,
当我们失去了我们爱的事物时，就会有那种哀悼和悲伤的行为。焦虑是其中的一部分，因为你可以在悲伤之前、期间和之后都有焦虑。所以它们是紧密相连的，而且肯定常常是人们一起表达出来的东西。我在自己的研究中发现，你知道的，人们会谈论焦虑，然后开始谈论这种焦虑如何指向他们所害怕的未来悲伤。所以他们某种程度上把它们联系在一起，即使他们还没有达到悲伤的阶段。我可以提出这样的看法吗：可能还有其他一些术语还没有被创造出来，
although there's a lot of language that's growing up around this whole phenomenon. But I was thinking about eco-exhaustion or eco-resignation, kind of a feeling that people might get by hearing about yet another crisis, about which you can't do anything, the devastating fires in Australia, the melting ice pack in Greenland. It seems that every day there's another. story about some part of the globe that is being racked by climate change. So do you sometimes feel, do you hear from people you work with that hope is lost? Yeah, the term that I use in that
尽管围绕这一整个现象正在滋生出许多语言。但我在想“生态精疲力竭”（eco-exhaustion）或“生态顺从”（eco-resignation），这是一种人们可能因为听到又一场危机而产生的感受，对于这场危机你却无能为力，比如澳大利亚毁灭性的火灾，格陵兰岛融化的冰盖。似乎每天都有另一个关于全球某个地方正饱受气候变化折磨的故事。所以你们有时会觉得，你们是否从共事的人那里听到希望已经破灭了？是的，我在这种
case is what I call a climate hostage. You know, we feel like we're kind of hostages to this larger process. And it is true because your average citizen doesn't have a lot of power to direct the government or corporations to address climate. So we do feel hostages. hostage to this. And I found, you know, part of part of the issue here is just validation. It's it's bearing witness to this issue, naming it, validating it. One of my little catchphrases in my practice with clients is, you know, validate, elevate, elevate, create. So, you know, we validate these problems, whatever the problem happens to be in your life. And then we elevate it. We lift it up. We say, this is important. We look at it from different angles and we get creative
情况下使用的词是我所称的“气候人质”。你知道的，我们觉得我们有点像这个更大过程的人质。这确实是真的，因为普通公民没有权力去指挥政府或企业来应对气候所以我们确实感到是人质。是这个人质。我发现，你知道的，这里的部分问题仅仅是确认（validation）。它是去见证这个议题，给它命名，对其进行确认。我在与客户的实践中的一个小口号是，你知道的，“确认、提升、创造”（validate, elevate, create）。所以，你知道的，我们确认这些问题，无论这个问题碰巧是你生活中的什么问题。然后我们提升它。我们把它举起来。我们说，这很重要。我们从不同的角度来看待它，并且我们针对它变得富有创造力
about it. What are we going to do about this? But yes, I think, I think that exhaustion, coupled with exhaustion about the economy, about COVID, about political polarization and things like that is very real for people. Dr. Consol, are you hearing the same thing, especially with the Inuit communities where you work? I mean, can you talk concretely about what they're saying and how this is all affecting their everyday lives? Yeah, in northern Labrador, where I work in the Nunez of land claim settlement region, which is an Inuit region of Labrador, you know, people have been experiencing climate change quite rapidly and quite aggressively for decades. So Labrador is one of the fastest warming places anywhere in the north. So Inuit, I've seen rapid decline of sea ice. So Inuit
。我们要对此做些什么？但是是的，我认为，我认为那种精疲力竭，再加上对经济、新冠疫情（COVID-19）、政治极化等事情的精疲力竭，对人们来说是非常真实的。孔索洛博士，你是否也听到了同样的说法，特别是在你工作的因纽特社区？我的意思是，你能具体谈谈他们在说些什么，以及这一切是如何影响他们的日常生活的吗？是的，在我工作的拉布拉多北部，努纳齐阿武特（Nunatsiavut）土地索赔定居区，这是拉布拉多的一个因纽特人地区，你知道的，几十年来，人们一直相当迅速且相当激进地经历着气候变化。因此，拉布拉多是北方变暖最快的地方之一。所以因纽特人，我看到了海冰的迅速减少。所以因纽特人
identify as people of the sea ice. So with this decline, not only is there a fundamental identity crisis, but there's also the inability to travel safely. So you're seeing more concern about people traveling on the ice during the winter, more injuries, more mortality. The inability to hunt as much, so to support and feed your family. So the sense of not only direct food security, but also the pride and strength that goes with those connections. The magnification of previous trauma when people, since we're talking about the hopeless sense, you know, people have experienced various types of really awful colonial processes, including forced relocation and land dispossession. And so now climate change is bringing up what what philosopher Glenn Albrecht calls Solissela,
把自己认同为海冰之民。因此，随着这种减少，不仅存在着根本性的认同危机，而且还无法安全出行。所以你会看到更多关于人们在冬季冰面上出行、更多伤害、更多死亡的担忧。无法进行那么多的狩猎，从而无法支持和养活你的家庭。因此，不仅直接的食物安全感丧失了，而且伴随这些联系的自豪感和力量也丧失了。当人们面对（既然我们在谈论绝望感）时，先前创伤的放大，你知道的，人们经历过各种真正可怕的殖民进程，包括被迫流离失所和剥夺土地。所以现在气候变化唤起了哲学家格伦·阿尔布雷希特（Glenn Albrecht）所称的“生态乡愁”（Solastalgia），
where people are in place and in their home community, but it no longer looks or feels like home. So there's a sense of homesickness without actually having to leave. So all of these, you know, overlap and interact. And that sense of hopelessness comes up a lot and people would talk about feeling powerlessness. And a number of people that we spoke with in the communities, and I've heard this elsewhere in the north and other indigenous populations, talked about it as another colonial process. You know, another piece where people from the outside are doing activities, that are directly taking away people's indigenous rights and their livelihoods and lifestyles.
即人们虽然身处原地和他们温暖的家乡社区，但它看起来或感觉起来不再像家了。因此，产生了一种无需离开就能感受到的乡愁。所有这些，你知道的，都在重叠和互动。这种绝望感经常出现，人们会谈论感到无力。我们在社区中交谈过的许多人（我在北方其他地方和其他原住民群体中也听过这种说法）将其称为又一个殖民进程。你知道的，这是又一个片段，外界的人在进行一些活动，
So I think, you know, the hopelessness is there, but then people also talk about a hope that I always think about as gritty hope. It's hope that's earned. So I love what Thomas said about this, you know, this identify, the validate, the elevate, the create, and that's what people are doing. So they're identifying it, they're saying,
这些活动直接剥夺了人们的原住民权利以及他们的生计和生活方式。所以我想，你知道的，绝望感是存在的，但人们也会谈论一种希望，我总是把它看作是“坚韧的希望”（gritty hope）。这是挣得的希望。所以我很喜欢托马斯关于这一点的说法，你知道的，这个“认同、确认、提升、创造”，这就是人们正在做的事情。所以他们正在识别它，他们说，
this is what we're experiencing, we've been at the front lines for decades, here are the things that we need to do, that we need to do, let's get creative about it. And there's a hope that comes from that that's gritty, that's earned, that's not this kind of Pollyanna hope of, oh, well, hopefully the government does something. It's something about, you know, communities coming together
这就是我们正在经历的，我们在几十年来一直身处前沿，这些是我们必须要做的事情，我们需要去做的事情，让我们对此发挥创造力吧。由此产生了一种希望，那是坚韧的希望，是挣得的希望，而不是那种“哦，好吧，希望政府能做点什么”的盲目乐观的希望。它是关于，你知道的，社区团结起来
and saying this is really awful, what are we going to do about it? Let's have hope because we can do this. We can pull on the strength of our communities and our ancestors. And so I think that's what I try to hold on to is not the hope that gives over power to the governments or the corporations, but it's a hope that's still there based on pain and kind of being forged through grief and loss and anxiety. What are you both telling people in your day-to-day work to help them cope and become more resilience in the face of something that is as overwhelming and formidable as climate change? Yeah, that's a great question.
并说这真的很糟糕，我们该怎么办？让我们怀有希望，因为我们能做到这一点。我们可以汲取我们社区和祖先的力量。所以我想这就是我努力坚持的东西，不是那种把权力拱手让给政府或企业的希望，而是一种仍然存在的希望，它基于痛苦，并在悲伤、损失和焦虑中被锻造出来。在面对像气候变化这样势不可挡且令人生畏的事情时，你们在日常工作中对人们说些什么来帮助他们应对并变得更具韧性？是的，这是一个很好的问题。
I really, actually, I really love the gritty, the concept of gritty hope. I'll definitely use that in the future. or hope that is earned. You know, I think we oscillate, and this, again, to step back a little bit on this conversation, many, many psychologists have tools to bear in this issue. I mean, many people, you know, especially in the clinical and counseling world, have worked with people dealing with grief or dealing with anxiety, you know, and we do know a bit about the grief process, you know,
我其实真的很喜欢“坚韧的希望”这个概念。我以后肯定会用它。或者说挣得的希望。你知道的，我认为我们在这之间摇摆，并且，为了在这个对话中稍微退后一步，许多许多心理学家拥有应对这个问题的工具。我的意思是，许多人，你知道的，特别是在临床和咨询界，曾与那些应对悲伤或应对焦虑的人一起工作过，你知道的，我们确实对悲伤的过程略知一二，你知道的，
and if we've dealt with it in our own personal lives in terms of losses and deaths and things. People tend to toggle between activities of grieving and mourning and disorganization and activities of growth and new beginnings, creativity. And this is a normal sort of oscillation. And so part of the more sophisticated way of working with this with clients and with the public is to really find people where they're at and where they are on that sort of oscillation curve. For some people, they need time to go into their grief and their loss and be deep within that, because that is a process that we go through until we work through those losses so we can reinvest our energy into life. For some people, they are wanting something upbeat. They are wanting a message of hope.
如果我们曾在自己的个人生活中处理过损失、死亡和类似事情的话。人们往往在悲伤和哀悼、无序的活动与成长、新开始、创造力的活动之间来回切换。这是一种正常的摇摆。因此，用一种更复杂的方式与客户和公众一起解决这个问题，就是要真正走到人们所在的地方，以及他们在那种摇摆曲线上所处的位置。对有些人来说，他们需要时间进入他们的悲伤和失落，并深深地沉浸其中，因为这是一个我们必须经历的过程，直到我们度过这些损失，这样我们才能把精力重新投入到生活中。对有些人来说，他们想要一些积极向上的东西。他们想要一个充满希望的信息。
Or they may be characteristically upbeat or more positive thinking, more resilient thinking. And so they, they, you know, resonate with messages around gritty hope and creativity and innovation and interesting science. I mean, there's a lot of really exciting, beautiful things about climate change and all the efforts all around the world that people are doing and have been doing around climate change. And particularly for the young people, they haven't been as jaded, perhaps, as someone who's been around this for many years. They're just coming into the world. and they deserve a fresh start. And so we have to be able to put ourselves in other people's minds, both people that are grieving, but also people that are fresh and are creative and want to make a difference.
或者他们可能性格上就是积极向上、或者更具积极思维、更具韧性思维的人。因此他们，你知道的，会对关于坚韧的希望、创造力、创新和有趣的科学的信息产生共鸣。我的意思是，关于气候变化以及世界各地人们正在做和一直在做的一切努力，有很多非常令人兴奋、美丽的事情。特别是对于年轻人来说，他们可能不像那些在这个问题上纠缠了很多年的人那样饱经沧桑。他们才刚刚来到这个世界，并且他们理应获得一个新的开始。因此，我们必须能够把自己置于其他人的心中，包括那些正在悲伤的人，但也包括那些充满朝气、富有创造力并希望有所作为的人。
And so as an interventionist, we have to do our own work. We have to spread ourselves out and be able to inhabit these different places. But it also can be a benefit for us. Dr. Consolo, we certainly know a lot about how young people are feeling about climate change as Dr. Doherty just said. And we know that we're suffering from, if they're suffering from eco-anxiety, are they too young to feel ecological grief?
因此，作为一名干预者，我们必须做好我们自己的工作。我们必须让自己能够适应并融入这些不同的地方。但这也能对我们有所帮助。孔索洛博士，正如托马斯刚才所说，我们当然对年轻人对气候变化的感受有很多了解。我们也知道，如果他们正在遭受生态焦虑，他们是否太年轻而无法感受到生态悲伤？
Well, I don't know. In the work that I do, like a lot of people identify in the research on the grief spectrum, absolutely. And again, this isn't clinical diagnosis work. This is people saying, you know, I am so sad. I'm in so much pain.
嗯，我不知道。在我所做的工作中，就像许多人在悲伤光谱的研究中所识别的那样，绝对是的。而且再次说明，这不是临床诊断工作。这是人们在说，你知道的，我太难过了。我在承受着这么多的痛苦，
But I think, you know, what I find really amazing is this validation piece that Thomas talks about. So when you ask, you know, what do I say to people? So I'm a non-practitioner, I'm not a mental health counselor, and I often point them to people like Thomas to say, look, the validation piece is you're not alone.
但我认为，你知道的，我发现真正令人惊叹的是托马斯谈到的这个“确认”部分。所以当你问，你知道的，我对人们说些什么？所以我是个非执业人员，我不是心理健康咨询师，我经常把他们指引给像托马斯这样的人，并说，看，确认部分就是你并不孤单。
There's a, you know, people who are eco-psychologists who are specifically looking at this. There's whole fields of study because there are people all over the world experiencing this. And I find in the work that we're doing with youth, that's something, youth are so, at least in my experience, are so much more open about talking talking about these things.
有一个，你知道的，有生态心理学家专门在研究这个。有整个的研究领域，因为世界各地都有人在经历这种感受。我发现在我们与年轻人合作的工作中，那是很明显的一点，年轻人，至少在我的经验中，在谈论这些事情时要开放得多。
And they don't carry the same shame that adults seem to carry to say, I'm sad about the environment. You know, when we first started this work 10 years ago, a lot of adults didn't want to admit that they had these emotions because they were embarrassed and they thought, oh, how silly, you know, I'm grieving the environments or I'm grieving this and they didn't want to talk about it. So they would say it privately, but so many people said, I've never told anyone this, I've never told my family, but I'm devastated, but I'm going to hide it because I'm so
而且他们没有成年人似乎背负的那种羞耻感，不敢说“我为环境感到难过”。你知道的，当我们10年前刚开始这项工作时，许多成年人不愿承认他们有这些情绪，因为他们感到尴尬，他们觉得，哦，多么愚蠢，你知道的，我在为环境感到悲伤或者我在为此悲伤，他们不想谈论它。所以他们会私下里说，但有那么多人说，我从未对任何人说过这话，我从未对我的家人说过，但我深受打击，但我打算把它藏起来，因为我太
embarrassed. Whereas youth just have this amazing ability now. And I think it's also because coming online with more and more of the decrease of stigma around mental health in general and the mental health advocacy and activism that young people have. And then they're just coming forward and they're openly saying like this is a normal response to losing things we love in this world. You know, the planet is suffering and of course we're going to suffer and that that's normal and healthy and we've got to be motivated by it. And that's what I find really really amazing. when you look at young people. And so I think they absolutely are sad and anxious and grieving, but they have a different capacity to express it without the other baggage that sort of adults seem to
尴尬了。而现在的年轻人只是拥有这种惊人的能力。我认为这也是因为随着围绕一般心理健康的精神污名化的日益减少，以及年轻人所做的心理健康倡导和激进主义，他们正在走出来，公开地说，这对于失去我们在这个世界所爱之物是一种正常的反应。你知道的，这个星球正在遭受痛苦，我们当然也会遭受痛苦，这是正常且健康的，我们必须以此为动力。这就是我发现真正、真正令人惊叹的地方，当你看着年轻人时。所以我认为他们绝对是悲伤、焦虑和悲伤的，但他们有不同的能力来表达它，而没有成年人似乎围绕羞耻、尴尬或害怕这样暴露自己而背负的其他包袱。而且这似乎是一个更正常、更健康的谈论回应。
have around shame or embarrassments or fear of exposing yourself like that. And it just seems a much more normal, healthy response for people to talk about. Some of what I tend to hear from younger people, though is anger like how could you adults how could you older people have wrecked the world and then brought us into it I mean how do we deal with with that you know I have a great feeling of guilt myself yeah some of this is existential I've you know taught in the college level and graduate level and and you know again we have to validate this it is something legitimately to be angry about you know I even in myself and my education just recently I've really become more aware of just
不过，我从年轻人那里听到的一些声音往往是愤怒，就像：你们这些成年人，你们这些老年人怎么能把世界搞砸了，然后又把我们带到这个世界上来？我的意思是，我们如何处理这种情绪？我自己也有一种强烈的内疚感。是的，其中一些是存在主义的。我曾，你知道的，在大学和研究生水平任教，并且，你知道的，我们再次必须对此进行确认，这确实是一件值得愤怒的事情。你知道的，甚至在我自己以及我最近的教育中，我也真正变得更加意识到，
the many decades of misinformation and propaganda around climate and stifling of the science. And President Johnson was briefed on climate change in 1965 with very, very clear information that mirrors what happens, you know, in our lives. And so there is truly injustice. I mean, and so we have young people, you know, trying to work through legal, through the courts. So, yeah, that is one angle here. There is climate injustice. There are people that have legitimately stymied, you know, healthy action on climate change. We've been able to take action on things like chloroflorocarbons or removing lead from gasoline and many other really difficult, you know, processes have been able to happen.
关于气候的几十年来的虚假信息和宣传，以及对科学的压制。约翰逊总统在1965年就听取了关于气候变化的简报，其中包含非常、非常清晰的信息，这些信息反映了我们生活中发生的事情。所以确实存在不公。我的意思是，因此我们有年轻人，你知道的，试图通过法律途径、通过法院来解决问题。所以，是的，这是一个切入点。存在气候不公。确实有人合法地阻挠了，你知道的，对气候变化的健康行动。我们已经能够对诸如氯氟烃（CFCs）或从汽油中去除铅等事情采取行动，并且许多其他非常困难的，你知道的，进程也得以发生。
But climate change has been politicized and stymie. So that anger that people feel is legitimate. But it's just one of many emotions. And so we, you know, one of the many images I use with people is, you know, the idea of a compass And a compass will point, you know, the needle will point north as you walk around and it'll move freely. So we want to have our emotions to be able to move freely. I will feel anger, but I also can feel hope. I can also feel happiness.
但气候变化被政治化和阻挠了。因此，人们感受到的这种愤怒是合乎情理的。但这只是众多情绪中的一种。所以我们，你知道的，我向人们使用的众多意象之一，你知道的，就是指南针的概念。指南针会指向，你知道的，当你走动时，针会指向北方，并且它会自由地移动。所以我们希望我们的情绪能够自由地移动。我会感到愤怒，但我也能感到希望。我也能感到快乐。
I can feel calmness. And so some of this, again, is emotional intelligence, basic psychology stuff. How do we feel a range of emotions? How do we, how can we be in the present moment? How do we do our own mental hygiene? You know, and young people do, you know, do well with mentoring about this kind of thing. You know, so there's a lot of ways that we can do. prevent more, we can help to direct the anger in a healthy, growthful way versus into a way of
我能感到平静。所以其中一些，再次说明，是情商，基础心理学的东西。我们如何感受一系列的情绪？我们如何，我们如何活在当下？我们如何做好我们自己的心理卫生？你知道的，年轻人确实，你知道的，很擅长接受关于这类事情的指导。所以有很多方法我们可以做到。我们可以阻止更多，我们可以帮助以一种健康的、促进成长的方式来引导愤怒，而不是引导走向
despair, jadedness, you know, self-hate, you know, the world might be a problem, but doesn't mean you are a problem. So again, there's that blame, there's a blame issue that we have to be careful about here, that people somehow think climate change is my, it's my fault. And part of that has been the misinformation that this has been put on individual people versus, you know, systems of power and corporations. So there's a whole political, critical piece here. Well, Dr. Consolo, you're in Canada. I'm just wondering, do you have the same sense of anti-science and climate change denial that
绝望、冷漠、你知道的，自我厌恶，你知道的，世界可能是一个问题，但这并不意味着你是一个问题。所以再次说明，这里有责备的问题，我们必须小心，人们不知何故认为气候变化是我的，是我的错。部分原因在于这种误导，即把这归咎于个人，而不是权力系统和公司。所以这里有一个完整的政治的、批判性的部分。好吧，孔索洛博士，你在加拿大。我只是想知道，你是否有同感，感受到我们在美国所经历的这种反科学和气候变化否定论？那里的情况是怎样的？
we have in the U.S.? What is it like there? I don't think it's to the extent that we've certainly seen come out of the U.S., particularly over the last four years. But we definitely do have it. And I don't think that Canada by any means is a place that is, you know, has clean hands in the climate misinformation. You know, we've gone through a number of things where governments have had different policies and haven't supported climate initiatives. And I think this is something that is a global political reckoning.
我认为它不像我们肯定看到从美国涌现出来的那么严重，特别是过去四年里。但我们确实有。我不认为加拿大在任何方面是一个手脚干净、没有气候虚假信息的国家。你知道的，我们经历过许多事情，当时政府有不同的政策，并且不支持气候倡议。我认为这是一个全球性的政治清算。
I absolutely agree with Thomas. This is something people have known about four decades. And the science has been clear for decades. but there hasn't been a will to globally act for a whole variety of reasons. So I do think it's something that people, that anger is legitimate about. I know that I go through bouts where I feel angry. But then for me and speaking personally, the anger is exhausting and it's not sustainable for me. So I have to find those other places to go to.
我完全同意托马斯的观点。这是人们已经了解了四十年的事情。几十年来科学一直很清晰。但由于各种各样的原因，一直缺乏全球行动的意愿。所以我确实认为这是人们可以理直气壮地感到愤怒的事情。我知道我会经历一些让我感到愤怒的时期。但对我而言，就个人而言，愤怒是令人筋疲力尽的，对我来说是不可持续的。所以我必须找到其他可以去的地方。
And I love that imagery of the compass, Thomas. I think that's just great because how do you hold the anger but move to the other things that are more productive, more positive, that for me personally, anger often debilitates, so I have to find ways to move into the other pieces. And I think I, you know, I hear a lot of young people. I know my own 16-year-old will sometimes say, you know, your generation and, you know, grandparents' generation, you really left us in a crisis, you know, and it's true, you know, and generations before, and we have a lot of reckoning.
我很喜欢那个指南针的意象，托马斯。我认为这真的很棒，因为你如何在保持愤怒的同时转向其他更有成效、更积极的事情？对我自己来说，愤怒常常让人虚弱，所以我必须找到方法转移到其他部分。而且我认为我，你知道的，我听到很多年轻人。我知道我自己的16岁孩子有时会说，你知道的，你们这一代和，你知道的，祖父母那一代，你们真的把我们留在了危机中，你知道的，确实如此，你知道的，还有之前的几代人，我们有很多需要清算的东西。
And I think it's something we can't leave to young people. And I think there's sometimes a sense that we're just going to leave it to the next generation. I think it's something that all generations need to work together. But I think anger is something we need to support. And that's where people like Thomas and other mental health professionals come in to provide that that mentoring support so people can work through and understand their experiences are legitimate. But how do they express them in positive, productive, healthy ways that won't harden themselves in the future?
而且我认为这是我们不能留给年轻人的事情。并且我认为有时有一种感觉，好像我们只要把它留给下一代就行了。我认为这是所有代际需要共同努力的事情。但我认为愤怒是我们支持的东西。这就是像托马斯和其他心理健康专业人士介入的地方，提供那种指导支持，以便人们能够克服并理解他们的经历是合乎情理的。但他们如何以积极、富有成效、健康的方式表达它们，而不会在未来让自己变得冷酷坚硬？
What kinds of changes are you both seeing in some psychological science with respect to climate change. Is this becoming much more of an accepted area of research and scholarship? I think from a research and scholarship perspective, we're seeing a lot. You know, there's just so much more coming online. And so much, people are really starting to look at it from multiple perspectives, which is really exciting to see. You know, we're seeing the longitudinal studies.
在心理学科学中，针对气候变化，你们双方都看到了什么样的变化？这是否正在成为一个更被广泛接受的研究和学术领域？我认为从研究和学术的角度来看，我们看到了很多。你知道的，有更多这样的内容涌现出来。而且有那么多，人们真的开始从多个视角来看待它，看到这一点真的很让人兴奋。你知道的，我们看到了纵向研究。
We're seeing case studies. We're seeing mixed methods. we're seeing population level, we're seeing the very clinical, the very social cultural piece. Like it's a very diverse field right now. But in many ways, it's still quite new. And I think that people's lived experiences with the mental health impacts of climate change really outstrip what we actually know. And I think that that's one of the huge challenges and often sometimes the failings of our field is we're not keeping up with what people are actually experiencing. And so there's so many unanswered questions, but people are already suffering around the globe. So how we, how we act
我们看到了案例研究。我们看到了混合方法。我们看到了群体层面，我们看到了非常临床、非常社会文化的层面。就像它现在是一个非常多元化的领域。但在许多方面，它仍然相当新颖。而且我认为人们对气候变化带来的心理健康影响的亲身经历，实际上超出了我们目前的实际认知。我认为这是巨大的挑战之一，也常常是我们这个领域的失败之处，我们没有跟上人们实际经历的步伐。所以有那么多未解之题，但全球各地的人们已经在遭受痛苦。因此，我们如何，我们如何迅速行动
quickly without needing to do more research, but also having the research to back up the actions is the real dilemma we're facing. Yeah, I think there's a conciliance here in the sense that people that have been working on disaster, disaster intervention that traditionally would work on fires and floods. That is now wrapping in more into the larger climate change, like climate change world and then especially recently social justice social justice issues now you know most climate active activism groups think of themselves as environmental justice groups so we have a we have a blending of the disaster work and the in the more office-based clinical work dealing with the stress and the anxiety from a distance and the social justice work and many people are self-motivating
而不需要做更多的研究，但同时也拥有支持这些行动的研究，这是我们面临的真正困境。是的，我认为这里有一种融合（consilience），即那些传统上从事火灾和洪水灾害干预的灾害干预人员。现在正在更多地融入到更大的气候变化世界中，特别是最近社会正义议题，现在，你知道的，大多数气候行动主义组织都认为自己是环境正义组织。因此，我们看到了灾害工作、以办公室为基础的、从远处处理压力和焦虑的临床工作以及社会正义工作的融合，许多人都在自我激励，
they're again they're getting ahead of the academy as actually saying and they're and practitioners are starting to work on this. And my goal was to try to knit this together in a really, you know, comprehensive way. So we don't have to reinvent the wheel. That's the thing I've noticed. You know, people come into this field. They don't realize that people have been working on this for many, many years. And, you know, I think that's the challenge for psychologists, how to get the, how to get all
他们再次走在了学术界的前面，正如阿什利所说，从业者也开始致力于此。我的目标是试图以一种非常，你知道的，全面的方式将这些编织在一起。这样我们就不必重复发明轮子了。这是我注意到的事情。你知道的，人们进入这个领域。他们没有意识到人们已经为此工作了许多、许多年。而且，你知道的，我认为这对心理学家来说是一个挑战，如何将，如何把
the stories together. So we're not in separate silos. What are the questions that we still need to answer about the main? mental health effects of climate change? What are you both studying now? There's so much, you know, and we can't individually study at all, but there is, there's so much we don't know. I'm particularly interested right now.
所有的故事拼凑在一起。这样我们就不会各自为战、身处不同的孤岛。关于主要的，我们仍然需要回答哪些问题？气候变化的心理健康影响？你们俩现在在研究什么？有太多的东西，你知道的，我们无法凭一己之力研究所有这些，但是，还有太多我们不知道的。我目前特别感兴趣的是，
I'm working with a team in Canada to look at a study on the prevalence and distribution at the population level for Canada of eco-anxiety and eco-grief and other mental health outcomes, because we don't have a population level study in Canada. And what we're running up against is when we talk to policymakers and decision makers, they'll say, well, it's great that there's all this research from other places or you have these case studies, but what are we actually looking at? So something in the way that the APA did where you can say, okay, two-thirds of people living in Canada express this. So that's something that I think is key, particularly from our country perspective.
我正在与加拿大的一个团队合作，研究加拿大在人口层面生态焦虑、生态悲伤和其他心理健康结果的患病率和分布情况，因为我们在加拿大没有全国人口层面的研究。我们遇到的大问题是，当我们与政策制定者和决策者交谈时，他们会说，嗯，其他地方的所有这些研究都很棒，或者你们有这些案例研究，但我们实际上面对的是什么？所以类似于APA所做的那样，你可以说，好吧，生活在加拿大的三分之二的人都表达了这一点。所以从我们的国家视角来看，我认为这是关键所在。
But I'm also particularly interested in those intersections that Thomas highlighted, like the social and climate justice, the mental health pieces, what we already know, and looking at some of the key projections. So there's very little research right now that looks at putting meteorological projections together with climate mental health outcomes. So being able to start to think about if we see, you know, this amount of warming by 2050, what does that mean for? depression, what does it mean for anxiety, what does it mean for violence and aggression? We have a little bit of research around suicide rates and temperature increase, but not for many other mental health outcomes. And then also looking at multi-country partnerships and initiatives. I think that's really key too, so we can start to get a bigger picture, but look at the place-based nuances that actually exists around the world.
但我也特别关注托马斯强调的那些交叉领域，比如社会与气候正义、心理健康部分、我们已经了解的内容，以及对一些关键预测的审视。因此，目前几乎没有什么研究将气象预测与气候心理健康结果结合起来看。所以我们要开始思考，如果我们在2050年看到这种程度的变暖，这对抑郁意味着什么，对焦虑意味着什么，对暴力和攻击性意味着什么？我们有一些关于自杀率与气温升高的研究，但对于许多其他心理健康结果则没有。此外，还要关注跨国合作与倡议。我认为这也是非常关键的，这样我们就能开始获得一个宏观的图景，同时关注世界各地实际存在的本土化细微差别。
I'm interested you mentioned suicide rates. Are they higher when it's hot or higher when it's cold? Yeah, higher when it's when it's hot. Yeah, so there's been work looking at US rates and Mexico rates. And, you know, with every like half degree temperature increase, there is an increase in numbers of suicides. So, and more people are starting to do that. There was one that did sort of a global, I forget, I think it was 14 different countries, and the information is all coming out the same. So as temperature rises, so do suicide rates.
我很感兴趣你提到自杀率。天气热的时候高还是冷的时候高？是的，天气热的时候高。因此，有一些针对美国和墨西哥自杀率的研究。而且，随着气温每升高约半度，自杀人数就会增加。所以，越来越多的人开始做这方面的研究。曾有一项研究涵盖了全球，我记不清了，好像是14个不同的国家，得出的信息都是一致的。因此，随着气温上升，自杀率也随之上升。
And then we've seen this before with heat-related aggression and violence. as well. So that type of research is starting to come where we're actually connecting, okay, with this amount of climate change projected in this region, it's likely we'll see, you know, this many more of these mental health outcomes. And I think that's really essential because it starts to make it real to people. It gives decision makers something to look at. It really brings it home when you start to think about loss of human lives or loss of quality of life. So I think we need more of that, which means bringing mental health professionals together with policy makers together with climate scientists and meteorological specialists and really working across disciplines and removing the silos, as Thomas mentioned. Yeah.
我们以前在与热有关的攻击性和暴力事件中也见过这种情况。这种研究正开始出现，我们实际上正在将“在这个地区预测到这种程度的气候变化”与“我们可能会看到这么多此类心理健康结果”联系起来。我认为这真的很重要，因为它开始让人们觉得这是真实的。它为决策者提供了一些可以参考的东西。当你开始思考人类生命的损失或生活质量的损失时，这种感觉真的很深刻。所以我想我们需要更多这样的研究，这意味着将心理健康专业人员与决策者、气候科学家以及气象专家聚集在一起，真正跨学科工作，消除托马斯提到的壁垒。是的。
And this is a great teachable moment because, you know, climate is the aggregate temperature over time versus the weather. And so what we find now is climate is changing our baseline. So in a community, there might be a baseline of suicidality in. general, but with climate change, it's not about specific heatways per se. It's just overall, our community levels will start to rise on some of these issues like suicidality. And this is a, this is what we need to understand about climate change. It's, it's raising levels broadly in society and changing our society in some ways. And so this distinction between climate and weather is a really interesting, interesting one to think about. You know, for myself, that there's two things that
这是一个绝佳的教育时刻，因为气候是随时间推移的总体温度，而天气则不同。所以我们现在发现的是，气候正在改变我们的基线。因此，在某个社区中，总体上可能存在自杀倾向的基线，但随着气候变化，这本身不单指特定的热浪。它只是总体而言，我们的社区水平开始在自杀倾向等问题上上升。这就是我们需要对气候变化有所理解的地方，它在广泛地提升社会层面的水平，并在某些方面改变我们的社会。因此，气候和天气之间的这种区别是一个非常有趣且值得思考的区别。对我个人而言，有两件事
I'm really focused on, one is training other providers and trying to as efficiently as possible bring people up to speed on being what we would call climate conscious counselor or doing ecotherapy. And so that's that's sort of helping them to develop their own environmental identity, their own backgrounds, their own strengths and weaknesses and competencies regarding nature of the natural world, outdoors, things like that. And then what skills do they already possess clinically in the sense of their their techniques and their background? And then how can they apply that unique background behavioral psychology or psychoanalytic psychology or whatever to their clients?
我真正专注于一件事是培训其他服务提供者，尽可能高效地让人们了解如何成为我们所说的气候意识咨询师，或者开展生态治疗。这有助于他们培养自己的环境认同、背景、对自然世界、户外等方面的优势、劣势和胜任力。然后，他们在临床上已经具备了哪些技能，包括他们的技术和背景？接着，他们如何将这种独特的行为心理学、心理分析心理学或其他背景应用到他们的来访者身上？
So there's a kind of a three-step process there with clinicians and trying to make this a little more streamlined. And I think that, you know, because it's urgent. This is an urgent. This is an urgent thing. And trying to dispel this idea that you cannot diagnose. You can't, there's no diagnosis of eco-anxiety. Yes, we can diagnose if necessary depression or anxiety, you know, regarding climate. There isn't need to be an environmental identity or environmental anxiety named diagnosis
所以对于临床医生来说，这有一个三步走的过程，并试图让这个过程更加顺畅。我认为，因为这是紧迫的。这是一件紧迫的事情。我们要努力消除“你不能诊断”这种观点。你可以诊断，生态焦虑并没有单一的诊断。是的，如果有必要，我们可以诊断与气候有关的抑郁或焦虑。并不需要专门命名一个环境认同或环境焦虑的诊断名称，
because that's not how the diagnosis system works. And so the goal is to not over-diagnose and pathologize people that are normal, but we also don't want to underserved people that are suffering. And so we have to set aside the politicization a bit and just look at the person and what do they need. And I would like to, you know, keep people in the healthy sphere, deal with adjustments and try to avoid the more deeper anxiety depression diagnosis if possible. But that's, I think, a really important thing to be working on right now. So it seems that there are some reasons to be hopeful that we're doing some good science, that there are opportunities. I just don't want to leave everybody on a down note here.
因为诊断系统不是那样运作的。因此，目标不是过度诊断和将正常人病理化，但我们也不想冷落那些正在受苦的人。所以我们必须把政治化放在一边，只关注这个人以及他们需要什么。我想让人们保持在健康的领域，处理适应问题，如果可能的话，尽量避免更深层的焦虑抑郁诊断。但我觉得这是目前非常重要的一项工作。所以看起来有一些理由让我们保持希望，因为我们在做很好的科学研究，还有各种机遇。我只是不想让大家在这里带着悲观的情绪离开。
or if there's something that you want to add that maybe will help people with their coping and resilience, or if they happen to be feeling a little bit of ego anxiety themselves. Well, I'll let Thomas have the last word on that one, because he's the clinical counseling specialists on this. But for me personally, I've never felt more hopeful about this area than I do right now because of the way people are coming together and because of the focus on it. And because of the way youth are talking about it, because of the way society is talking about it, We're grappling with it now. We're identifying it.
或者如果你有什么想要补充的，可能会帮助人们应对和恢复，或者如果他们自己刚好感到一丝生态焦虑的话。好吧，我把这最后发言的机会留给托马斯，因为他是这方面的临床咨询专家。但就我个人而言，由于人们聚集在一起的方式、人们对它的关注，以及年轻人谈论它的方式、社会谈论它的方式，我从来没有像现在这样对这个领域感到如此充满希望。我们现在正在努力应对它。我们正在认识它。
We're acknowledging it. We're acting on it. So that for me, I've never felt more hopeful than I do now. Yes. I mean, I really love, actually actually talked about strengths of ancestors. And so again, certain people really need that message of, they need a message of strength. They need a message of hope.
我们正在承认它。我们正在采取行动。因此，对我来说，我从未像现在这样感到如此充满希望。是的。我的意思是，我真的很喜欢，刚才其实谈到了先辈的力量。所以同样，某些人确实需要那种信息，他们需要一种力量的信息。他们需要一种希望的信息。
They need a message of creativity. And so I, again, it's meeting, whoever's listening to this, wherever you're feeling, normal, right? And if you do have hope and as you like to get excited about ideas, that's great. And, you know, there is a despair and empowerment curve that we all navigate where we get excited about ideas and we get, we try things and we learn. And then we make mistakes and then we get tired and fatigued. One of my sayings, again, despair is fatigue and disguise. And so we get tired, we get fatigued. We get into a trough. We get we get hopeless.
他们需要一种创造力的信息。所以，无论谁在听这个，无论你有什么感受，这都是正常的！如果你有希望，并且你喜欢对各种想法感到兴奋，那很好。而且，我们所有人都在经历一个绝望与赋能的曲线，我们对各种想法感到兴奋，我们去尝试，我们去学习。然后我们犯了错误，接着我们感到疲惫和倦怠。我的名言之一就是，绝望是伪装的疲惫。所以我们累了，我们倦怠了。我们陷入低谷。我们变得绝望。
less. But then, again, life goes on. So we, over time in this kind of work, we learn to navigate the waves. And I think that's a longer-term process that's helpful for people to know. Well, thank you both for joining us today. This has been a really interesting and edifying discussion. I really appreciate your taking the time. And the work that you both are doing is very, very important. Thank you. Thank you, Kim. Thanks so much, Kim. You can learn more about psychologists' work on eco-anxiety, climate change, and mental health. in the March issue of APA's magazine Monitor on Psychology.
不过随后，生活仍在继续。因此，随着时间的推移，在这样的工作中，我们学会了驾驭这些波澜。我认为这是一个更长期的过程，对人们了解这些是有帮助的。好的，非常感谢两位今天加入我们的节目。这是一次非常有趣且富有启发性的讨论。非常感谢你们抽出时间。你们俩正在做的工作非常非常重要。谢谢你们。谢谢你，金。非常感谢，金。你可以通过美国心理学会（APA）杂志《心理学观察》（Monitor on Psychology）的三月刊，了解更多关于心理学家在生态焦虑、气候变化和心理健康方面的工作。
Visit the show notes on our website for a link. You can also find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman, Our sound editor is Chris Kondyyan.
访问我们网站上的节目说明即可获取链接。你也可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 上，或者在 Apple、Stitcher 以及任何你获取播客的平台上，找到往期的《心理学访谈》（Speaking of Psychology）节目。如果你对未来的播客有任何评论或想法，请发电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。也就是 Speaking of Psychology，全部连在一起，发到 apa.org。《心理学访谈》由李·维纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作，我们的音频剪辑师是克里斯·孔迪扬（Chris Kondyyan）。
Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听美国心理学会的节目。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。